yeah yeah yeah i've never plowed through
[ __ ] before
you know what i mean i've been inside
them you've plowed
you've been with many many many partners
so yes you've got wow
okay well if you're so you're saying
plowing is of sex yeah it's just going
through a like a a
large amount of a large number of crops
of crops a lot of crops right but what
i'm saying is is that but my crops is a
smaller land
it's a smaller farm it's not like i know
dudes that have like
these corporate farms
and they do massive farms
irrigation and whatnot right and i'm
sort of a mom-and-pop one like i do
organic
you know i mean you're yeah you're
stable is smaller almost yeah so plowing
would be appropriate then yeah yeah yeah
i see you as a plower thank you you're
welcome yeah is everyone a plower that
does it or no no no no no oh good thank
you i'm so i'm in an elite level
wait what a girl like when the guys are
out we have this type of slang weird but
when you're out with the girls like
hanging out at uh it's you know the
palmolive factory or wherever you go
[Laughter]
like what are the words you guys used to
say like horrible things
like getting dick down catching a dick
skull [ __ ] catching it like skull what
yeah
i'm not a character in thor
[Laughter]
wait what keeps going
uh girls are pr way more graphic about
um describing sex than men are with each
other because i think that you know
there's a
yeah it's like men do
the bragging we do the details like
they're really graphic stuff to the t
like do you have an ingrown hair here
this that you know the scooting motion
all of it is being talked about
so um
you guys do i it would break my heart
yeah and i feel like you've done this
about you yeah like you've like
dick shamed me wow i have been obviously
honestly
honest
because i genuinely love your penis
i love the way you have sex i love your
penis i've always had fun having sex
with you baby he's a plower i've always
i've never said anything bad about you
which is why we were together for 10
years yeah i have i talked [ __ ] about
dudes in the past usually when they're
not nice
af when they're not
you know what i mean like you know when
you've been used for sex right
those dudes it's fair game i'll say
whatever the [ __ ] i want to say but no
not about partners i would never do that
boy you said fun
that that i just when you say fun i
picture
a bunch of children with no legs in a
bouncy house
how is he fun actually like
he is that doesn't seem fun to me that's
not funny yeah that seems horrifying but
what it what did you mean fun i've never
heard that associated he always had you
know you can always
i've been with men who i know have
watched porn and are trying to mimic or
almost orchestrate this like perfect sex
scenario yeah he's never given up he's
been weird in bed like he does
he has his own style his old his own
rhythm he's just free he's free i'm free
man you're like what i do on stage yeah
yeah i do it in the [ __ ] bed goes
through so you're having sex you're like
hey carrot head there's a mashed potato
in the back your ass crack and then
bang
plow so we are kind of this yeah we're
just saying we just do it in bed and i
do it on stage yeah this is how guys
talk about it right and i always like
how gentle you are you're kind of i'm
[ __ ] gentle as [ __ ] he's a really
gentle person what do you mean like hold
you
no no no like you're not like
you don't have that like machismo like
ah you know like you don't do that he's
got raccoon hands
[Laughter]
raccoons they're like yeah
[Laughter]
wow with the mask on your face yeah
you never [ __ ] shamed me
well this is what you do
and i've noticed that i've never talked
about this before yeah right is you know
when i pull out and i jerk off to come
yeah right you get into it like a you
sit down indian style that's not the way
you said it native americans native
american style right and you look at me
and you tilt your head
like a dog yeah
in like
almost like you're
mesmerized by but also questioning it
like
so i'm joking
you know i'm here right
yeah yeah okay yeah so
you chew up your fly at least dude
your dick's out all right all right
dick i know you're a christian i'm so
sorry man i am now
i was atheist when i walked through the
door but after watching you do your
marcel marceau mime show over there i'm
ready to walk through a wall and punch
casper in the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so you don't like it